selling wine in August what does that
actually mean let me tell you a story I
get involved in my dad's liquor store
and I say dad why are we always running
ads during Thanksgiving and Christmas
and Easter and he goes son that's when
people buy wine I go that's not what it
looks like to me because people are
coming in here every single day and this
was in the mid 90s and something kind of
clicked to me which was Oh everybody
markets at the same time because they
presume that's when people are drinking
buying listening to music buying eating
food I don't care what it is this is the
time they do X meanwhile there's a ton
of people doing it all the time why am I
telling you this the Oscars just
happened and every brand was out there
making real-time content trying to break
through and jump on the next meme
because of what happened the Super Bowl
a year before and so during the Grammys
and during the Oscars ignoring this last
Super Bowl I see brands and businesses
keep trying to jump in and say something
funny meanwhile on a day like today an
average Tuesday Wednesday Thursday in
the middle of nowhere you can do
something micro one little trend of one
little conversation in the world where
there's far less noise and over-deliver
I somehow I don't know how convinced my
dad to advertise mine full-page ads in
August the deadest season and you know
what happened we won because we were the
only ones talking so for everybody back
home right now trying to figure out how
to say something really cool during the
Kentucky Derby or during the next big
event I promise you find something cool
or worthwhile to say during next Friday
when nothing's going on
later'd into pop culture that's going on
at that moment and you will break
through because none of the other brands
and businesses are talking and you're
the only one easy supply and demand of
attention my friends supply and demand
of attention